with days to go until the deadline for
troop withdrawal from afghanistan in the
midst of a humanitarian crisis the
taliban agreed to meet sky news in doha
and issued this stark warning
if the us or the uk
wanted to extend the 31st
of august deadline in order to
[Music]
continue evacuations out of the country
would you agree to that no no
this is something
you can say it's a red line president
biden
announced
this agreement that until uh 31st of
august they would withdraw all their
military forces
so if they extend it that means they are
extending occupation while there is no
need for for that i think that it will
deteriorate the relation that will
create mistrust between us if they
are intent on continuing the occupation
so it will
provoke reaction
let's talk about the situation at the
airport people are very afraid of what
life may look like under your rule
people are prepared to leave everything
behind they're prepared to risk their
lives to leave the country
what would be your message to them
first i assure you it is not about their
worry and not about their scare their
this is about
the they want their demand to resettle
in western countries
and that is a kind of economic migration
because afghanistan poor country and 70
percent of the people of afghanistan are
living under the line of poverty so
everyone wants to resettle in
western countries to have a prosperous
life
so that that is
it is not about scared of course for
their justification to go there they
exaggerate scare and terrified and so
and so so we know the other ones this is
our society
this is not the fact they are scared
we're hearing reports of members of the
taliban going door-to-door looking for
people like journalists like
members of the judiciary former
government workers we're hearing that
girls schools have been closed in some
provinces
what are you doing about that
all fake reports
if anyone is as you say
and we investigate every incident
who is being door-to-door he himself
will be prosecuted and tried and
punished
because that is a violation of our
policy but i can assure you there are
many reports by our opening opponents
claiming uh what is not based on
realities
and as we now approach the date for
american british foreign forces soldiers
to leave afghanistan
what would you say to the families of
those who died trying to help
afghanistan
i first of all say
they acquired our country
if we
occupy your country what you will say
to me
i
killed
your people
in your country
what you will say
i think
our people
suffer the lot bloodshed destruction
everything but
we say the past is
the past story
a part of the our
part of our past history
now we want to focus on future